good morning john preface i don't know
when this is gonna end but i did just
get
my first vaccine shot so i'm feeling
good i'm starting to wonder
what a lot of people are wondering which
is like what do we keep and what do we
not keep i don't know why this stuck
with me but this is something my boss
said to me when i worked at walmart he
said
it's 10 or 100 times easier to keep
somebody coming to the same store
than to attract them to a new store
which was him saying like we need to
treat our customers really well because
we lose them
it's very hard to get them back the
point is our behavior is sticky we are
creatures of habit and doing the same
thing like going to the same store
has like benefits to it i know when it's
gonna be busy i know where the ketchup
is and where the peanut butter is the
peanut
peanut butter is put all over different
stores no one can agree where it goes
every activity has built-in costs of
switching we incurred a lot of costs
switching to this new way and
now like a lot of this seems pretty
normal there's a lot of behaviors that
have changed and i'd like some of them
to go back to the way they were
and like some of them to stay the way
that they are like me wearing a mask on
an airplane why wasn't i doing that
before but there's another dimension to
this it's not just the things that i'd
like to keep doing versus the things
that i'd like to
go back to how they were before the
pandemic there's also whether or not
those things are actually gonna happen
like i would like to never travel for
business again and that's been a nice
thing for me this year
i'm going to though and so with what is
possibly an over abundance of hope i
have created
my personal post-covered behavior change
alignment chart things that i want to go
back to that will definitely will happen
include hugging hugging
people other than my wife and son and
then on the opposite from that there's
the things
that i would frankly like to keep but
will not like never traveling for
business
also in that quadrant i'm afraid zoom
calls with old friends
like we started doing this because of
the pandemic i'm not sure that we'll be
able to keep it up even though i do like
it there's only one thing in my want to
go back to but may not be able to
quadrant
and that is feeling like safe around
strangers
in the way that i used to i'm not sure
how long this is gonna take but like
right now
i think i would be pretty uncomfortable
in a big crowded room the nice thing
about this is that it also sort of like
lets you experience the extremes of
these things like i kind of want to go
see a movie but not that bad
like i'm gonna go see movies again but
if we're being honest and like i know
i've got a four-year-old so that's a
little more complicated for me but like
and there is stuff that i'd like to keep
the same and i think that i will like i
want to do more telemedicine now i'm not
sure if i'll be able to
if my doctor will provide that option
but it's been great it's hard for me a
person who has
a lot of advantages and privileges to
get to the doctor's office why would we
make a single mom like get
child care so that she could get to the
doctor's office and wait there in order
to get a prescription
for a uti that will require the exchange
of like 15 words
that's not an efficient system for
anyone but a less extreme thing and more
likely to actually happen
a lot of my favorite restaurants started
doing delivery when they didn't before
and i kind of like having a night in
where i don't have to do dishes but also
don't have to go anywhere with a
four-year-old i've posted a blank
version of the post-covered behavior
change alignment chart if you want to
fill out your own and post it on twitter
you can use
a hashtag i'll put it in the description
but i think the most important part of
this exercise
for me has been some of these things are
going to be my choice and some of them
aren't and it's nice to think what might
happen what i might do but it's also
possible
that i'll be wrong and i will end up not
doing the thing
because behavior is really sticky but a
message to future hank
if you're watching this if you're not
having your friends over to like hang
out
as often as possible what are you
thinking get your
butt together this hank misses it so
much do me a favor
give them a call make them some
margaritas
john i'll see you on tuesday